[Musique]
le Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI invité
aujourd'hui François Bayrou au
commissaire aux plans et maire de Pau le
débat est dirigé par Benjamin sportou
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio de RTL2 bonjour François Bayrou
bonjour merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui à mes côtés pour vous
interroger Guillaume Rocket du Figaro
bonjour Guillaume et Adrien LCI 7
émission et bien sûr en direct jusqu'à
13h vous pouvez adresser toutes vos
questions vos interpellations à votre
invités hashtag le Grand Jury sur tous
les réseaux sociaux et Marie-Pierre
Haddad viendra relayer tout cela en fin
d'émission
alors François Bayrou en avril dernier
vous prédisiez que les Français auraient
envie je vous cite d'aller prendre l'air
plutôt que d'aller voter aux régionales
l'abstention record vous a donné raison
mais quel intérêt de voir juste d'être
Oracle quand personne ne vous écoute
vous pensiez pourtant avoir l'oreille
d'Emmanuel Macron François Bayrou il ne
vous a pas entendu vous avez aussi parlé
dans le vide quand vous réclamiez la
proport personnel tout comme un plan
Marshall pour relancer l'industrie
française mais nous y reviendrons dans
cette émission est-ce le signe que votre
parole ne porte plus ou que le chef de
l'État n'écoute pas y compris ses
propres alliés dont vous êtes dont le
modèle est au sein de la majorité ou
est-ce les deux du coup on s'interroge
aussi sur votre utilité véritable la
tête du Haut Commissariat aux plantes
censé dessiner l'avenir alors même que
les préoccupations des Français sont
d'abord
immédiates et qu'ils exigent de leur
politique qu'ils y répondent et dit la
prochaine présidentielle ce sera bien
sûr dans le débat sur fond tout cela de
pandémie toujours menaçante la première
question vous est posée par Adrien ce
matin dans le Journal du dimanche près
de 100 médecins réclament la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants sans
tarder on sait que le gouvernement est
réfléchi est-ce que vous considérez
qu'il faut franchir le pas et y aller
est-ce que les députés de votre partie
voteront ce texte s'il est présenté à
l'assemblée depuis le premier jour de
l'épidémie
et ça m'a valu bien des polémiques j'ai
pensé que la seule issue était la
vaccination
et je pense que un jour ou l'autre dans
un pays où je vous le rappelle chaque
bébé qui naît reçoit 11 vaccinations
obligatoires
dans un pays où pour aller dans un
département français la Guyane il faut
être obligatoirement vacciné contre la
fièvre jaune
autrement dit la vaccination ça fait
partie de la vie et c'est probablement
la conquête médicale avec l'hygiène la
plus importante depuis le début des
temps et c'est un Français pasteur qui
l'a inventé alors et donc moi j'ai
toujours pensé que ça finirait par la
décision collective de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour toute la
population pour mettez-moi de dire
quelque chose ne regardons pas pour
toute la population la vaccination
obligatoire comme comme les 11
vaccinations qu'on donne au bébé à la
naissance et à partir de quel âge on
peut faire des des échéances
je vais vous dire quelque chose qui va
peut-être vous surprendre moi je vis
avec une hantise en face de ce virus
c'est qu'un jour une mutation
atteigne face que le virus devienne
nocif et extrêmement nocif pour les
enfants
jusqu'à maintenant au fond la société
n'a pas été
en profondeur bouleversée elle a été en
profondeur changée arrêté elle a dû mais
elle n'a pas été en profondeur
traumatisée jusqu'à l'âme parce que ça
touche des populations plus fragiles et
des personnes âgées ce qui est
naturellement extrêmement grave mais ça
ne ça ne met pas en cause l'âme d'un
peuple si ça touchait les enfants
et les enfants en bas âge alors je crois
qu'on se trouverait devant des des
vagues
qui mettraient en cause la stabilie même
la stabilité même de l'association
obligatoirement faire pour se prémunir
contre des mutations pour se prémunir
contre des mutations il faut que on
freine la propagation du virus alors et
on ne comprenait à partir de quel âge
que par la vaccination et ça c'est les
enfants qui doivent le dire je
rencontrais hier des personnes qui font
vacciner leurs enfants à l'âge de 12 ans
pour que ils puissent avoir la liberté
d'aller devenir de participer à des à
des rencontres familiales ou
amical c'est au médecin de te le dire
mais en tout cas la vaccination c'est la
seule digue
contre ce qui nous pend au nez ce qui
menace d'arriver qui est une quatrième
vague pourquoi pas une cinquième vague
vous avez vu les mutations qui sont en
cours et qui sont en Grande-Bretagne
mais François si on dit on rend la
vaccination obligatoire pour tout le
monde par exemple quoi qu'on le dira un
jour est-ce que vous souhaitez c'est ce
que vous nous dites aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours pensé que c'était la solution
que fait-on dans ce cas-là pour ceux qui
refusent de se faire vacciner il y a
aujourd'hui des gens qui disent je ne me
ferais pas vexer
commençons par la persuasion et par
l'incitation avant droit
je connais des gens de très bonne foi
qui ont peur de se faire vacciner je
pense que cette peur est irraisonnée on
a 30 millions de personnes vaccinées en
France
combien d'accidents
qui est nouveau dans sa technologie ce
fameux ARN messager est-ce que c'est
vraiment nouveau c'est une autre
question mais ça va être à n'en pas
douter une arme formidable contre pas
seulement les virus mais contre un
certain nombre de maladies on pense au
cancer il y a des tumeurs qui seront qui
vont être
éradiqués grâce à l'ARN messager vous ne
craignez pas un message envoyé au
système immunitaire pour cibler
quelqu'un avoir en réaction un mouvement
d'hostilité si on rend les choses
obligatoires n'est-ce pas quand vous
êtes un gouvernant ou quand vous êtes un
responsable
il y a toujours la certitude que
quelques décisions que vous prendrez
vous aurez un mouvement d'hostilité je
ne connais pas de décision importante
qui n'est pas provoquée de mouvement
d'hostilité mais la grandeur
de la responsabilité d'un dirigeant
c'est de dire écouter en conscience j'ai
profondément consulté travailler
réfléchi sur ce sujet en conscience je
vous dis que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
vous dites il faut persuader je dis
c'est première étape persuadé inciter
alors par exemple on pourrait le faire
concrètement est-ce que vous seriez
favorable est-ce qu'on réserve l'accès
aux transports en commun aux gens qui
sont vaccinés en faisant un contrôle de
passeport sanitaire à montrer des métros
que pour les spectacles c'est comme ça
que ça va se passer pour les rencontres
sportives c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer vous ne pourrez entrer en tribune
que si vous pouvez faire la preuve que
vous avez participé vous-même à la lune
est-ce qu'on va absolument à ce qu'on
fait pour les restaurants est-ce qu'on
le fait dans les trains par exemple
est-ce qu'on viendra voilà je pense que
assez vite vous avez entendu les
médecins les épidémiologistes qui disent
la quatrième vague ça se joue maintenant
la quatrième vague c'est au nombre de
vaccinés aujourd'hui qu'on va savoir si
on peut freiner ou empêcher cette
quatrième vague qui nous pend on est
vous avez bien vu le variant que vous
nous dites François Valéry un projet de
loi du gouvernement pour rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants puis pour la population
générale vous le voteriez
le groupe du mot non mais le groupe du
modèle chacun est libre d'accord
[Musique]
j'essaierai moi-même de persuader et
d'inciter et de suivre donc les deux
premières les deux premiers étapes les
deux premiers actes que je recommande
est-ce que vous craignez des tensions
entre vacciner et non vaccinés non
sur les 30 millions de vaccinés vous
auriez fait un sondage il y a 6 mois 15
millions vous aurez dit je veux pas être
vacciné puis ils ont vu autour d'eux que
ça se passait très très bien qu'il y
avait deux jours ou un jour et demi où
on est un peu un peu fiévreux souvent à
la deuxième vaccination quand ce sont
des des vaccins à RN messager bon et
puis c'est passé et puis tout le monde
est en bonne santé puis il y a aucun
problème
car il n'y a aucun problème là
il y a parfois des effets secondaires
qui sont qui sont forts
la vaccination ça n'est pas un
affaiblissement de l'organisme c'est un
renforcement de l'organisme c'est en
quoi pasteur a été absolument génial en
inventant et dans des circonstances de
risque incroyable le vaccin contre la
grippe la médecine de l'avenir sera une
médecine fondée sur l'immunologie en
grande partie fondée sur l'immunologie
et les thérapies géniques c'est une
mutation qui est en cours et donc il
faut rassurer il n'y a pas dans
l'immense immense dans la quasi-totalité
des cas il n'y a aucun effet secondaire
alors après bien sûr dans toute activité
humaine il peut y avoir un accident
j'entendais un grand médecin raconter
que si on vous injectait de l'eau salée
il pouvait y avoir des accidents enfin
de de
du liquide
physiologique François Bayrou donc vous
nous dites en effet qu'il faut donc
cette vaccination obligatoire à terme il
y a un autre sur le gouvernement droit
donc se prononcer se positionner il va
consulter il est en train de consulter
les élus locaux autre sujet sur lequel
le prix en de la République va devoir
arbitrer c'est bien sûr la réforme des
retraites François Bayrou c'est un sujet
très important vous avez dit aussi même
il y a quelques mois que vous étiez
défavorable à une réforme d'ici la
présidentielle êtes-vous toujours sur
cette ligne mon problème c'est que je
change pas souvent d'avis et vous savez
qu'il arrive comme le reproche donc je
pense que la période électorale n'est
pas favorable pour faire passer
à la va-vite une réforme je pense que le
Président de la République s'il se
représente les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle vont chacun défendre un
principe de réforme et ça aura valeur de
une orientation extrêmement forte
j'ajoute que ayant mais en effet mais
mes lignes de conduite moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu'une réforme difficile comme la
réforme des retraites il n'y avait qu'un
moyen de la faire passer sans bloquer le
pays c'est de dire que au terme de sa
préparation c'est les Français qui
choisiraient donc qui adopteraient pas
référendum vous n'êtes pas sensible
sur cette cette réforme vous dites pas
maintenant mais j'ai pas ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire dit il faut
montrer que la France continue à se
réformer ne serait-ce que parce qu'elle
est lourdement endettée et donc il faut
rassurer les gens qui nous ont prêté de
l'argent nous sommes à 6 mois de
l'élection présidentielle chacun peut
avoir ses préférences quant au rythme
moi je suis extrêmement attentif
extrêmement attentif au caractère
comment dirais-je de participation des
citoyens
si vous avez vu tous les syndicats sans
exception se sont prononcés et le
patronat aussi en disant faut juste
qu'on respire à cette rentrée et
naturellement faudra reprendre les
réformes après mais si on fait
l'élection présidentielle forme mais
juste par exemple ce que propose
certains repousser l'âge légal à 64 ans
sans faire le système universel
peut-être sans faire les régimes vous
voyez que moi je ne sais pas ce que veut
dire faire des fragments de réforme
alors bon c'est au président de la
République de choisir mais vous lui avez
dit et il connaît mon avis je crois et
donc le
et je sais que lui
envisage toutes les hypothèses et
l'envisage cette réforme c'est donc mais
permettez-moi deux phrases sur sur le
sur ce que vous avez dit
moi je pense qu'il manque une arme à la
démocratie française une arme décisive
c'est que le référendum est totalement
dénaturé parce que c'est de Gaulle a
voulu comme ça aussi c'est un coup près
ça veut dire stop ou encore c'est une
motion de censure ou une motion de
soutien en direct de l'opinion et ça
devrait pas servir à ça si on regarde la
Suisse qui je considère montre de ce
point de vue là un exemple le référent
d'homme en Suisse sert à trancher des
questions complexes pour que cette
décision populaire ne soit pas très
faible taux de participation à François
Bayrou dans les votations suisses mais
on va dire sur l'abstention on va on va
venir à ça mon
mon sentiment et qu'il y a un certain
nombre de questions dans lesquels on
serait plus fort si on les faisait
trancher par les retraites et si on les
remettait à leur décision c'est à dire
la présidentielle est juste après on
consulte les Français au moment des
législatifs parce que d'une certaine
manière la présidentielle va servir
d'orientation
je reviens sur les principes
si on allait à une réforme qui soit une
réforme qui heurte qui rencontre la
résistance d'une grande partie des
organisations par exemple syndical et
patronales qu'est-ce qui se passerait oh
je passerai quelque chose d'extrêmement
simple le pays serait bloqué quand vous
pensez qu'il y a eu des blocages de
certains syndicats dans les aéroports et
dans les trains le premier jour du
départ en vacances et que ça heurte le
sentiment populaire à un point que qu'il
est difficile d'imaginer donc dans le
mode vous trouvez ça scandaleux pardon
de trouver sa scandaleux c'est grave de
ce week-end je trouve ça
à l'encontre de tous les devoirs que
nous avons les uns envers les autres
n'est-ce pas les salariés en question
ont été soutenus par l'État à 100% de
leur revenu et par les grandes
entreprises auxquelles ils participent à
100% de leur revenu pendant une qui a
duré un an et le lendemain on déclenche
des grèves je trouve ça
insensé je trouve ça je trouve que ça
heureuse le sentiment de bon sens
élémentaire qui celui qui devrait faire
servir de ciment à une nation donc
revenons et donc retraite vous dites
référendum non mais je prends les
retraites comme exemple je
préfère une consultation populaire à un
blocage du pays mais ça veut dire que
pendant les 10 mois qui viennent
François Bayrou on ne peut plus réformer
je suis persuadé qu'il y a un certain
nombre de réformes par exemple en
direction des jeunes
qui peuvent être acceptes qui peuvent
être très importantes
accepter dans un consensus large et qui
peuvent montrer que au contraire
ce sentiment réformateur il est
extrêmement fort c'est à la garantie
jeune universelle je pense moi je pense
qu'à des
garanties pour soutenir les jeunes qui
entrent dans le monde du travail doivent
y entrer et pour les aider à y entrer le
RSA jeune par exemple est-ce qu'il a vos
faveurs ou pas donné à tous les jeunes
et bien le même montant est-ce que ça ça
n'est pas mon pourquoi spontanément j'ai
le sentiment que c'est
[Musique]
que ça ne que ça ne conduit pas
les jeunes vers la responsabilité et
vers le monde du travail qui doit être
leur horizon je sais bien que ces
populaires que sûrement ça coûte
sûrement très cher mais ça n'est pas
l'argument majeur l'argument majeur il
faut que la société soit en soutien de
ce de ce passage qui est un passage
difficile vers le monde du travail vous
souvenez vous vous souviendrez que que
dans que dans une élection
présidentielle j'avais proposé qui est
un droit à la première expérience
professionnelle il y a une quand vous
êtes jeune quand vous arrivez à l'âge
après le diplôme ou avant le diplôme
mais quand vous ne suivez on vous
garantisse que vous aurez une première
expérience professionnelle ça vous
souhaitez que ce soit dans le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron candidat c'est lui qui
d'abord s'il se présente s'il décide de
se présenter et c'est si jamais ce sont
des
lorsque vous êtes président de la
République vous avez à la fois
l'expérience et le souci de cette
responsabilité de cette fonction si
importante mais qu'est-ce qu'il
empêcherait d'être à chaque instant vous
vous posez la question et il est naturel
que le Président de la République c'est
la pause je ne doute pas qu'il se la
pose moi je pense que sa décision sera
de se représenter mais
jusqu'au bout il est libre
c'est un homme qui aime beaucoup sa
liberté et vous souhaitez qu'il se
représente oui je pense c'est
aujourd'hui le la personnalité la plus
la plus solide la plus à la hauteur de
cette
nous poserons la question le moment venu
si jamais il venait il sait pas non je
reviens au réforme il y en a une autre
qui était en cours qui était là la
réforme de l'allocation chômage alors le
Conseil d'État bloqué le gouvernement
mais qui a dit on nous allons la faire
quand même on va
réfléchir à la façon de la représenter
là il a tort vous croyez que ça aussi il
faudrait le suspendre jusqu'à ce qu'il
faut quand vous avez conduit un texte à
son terme et qu'il est bloqué pour des
raisons
comme vous le dites du Conseil d'État
considère que la conjoncture économique
n'est pas suffisamment bonne pour
pouvoir moins bien indemniser le chômage
bon je suis pas
[Musique]
contester le Conseil d'État m'impose
moi-même d'avoir un peu mais vous vous
rendez bien compte qu'une juridiction
qui juge de l'opportunité en fonction de
la conjoncture économique c'est comment
dirais-je surprenant
donc mais moi je ne je constate je pense
qu'il faut que le gouvernement regarde
de près l'argumentaire du Conseil d'État
et qu'ils prennent la décision d'y
répondre de manière à ne pas en effet
tout bloquer et pour relancer l'activité
vous allez proposer un plan Marshall
Adrien geindre le gouvernement lui a
déjà engagé un premier plan de relance
il y a beaucoup de voix qui sont élevés
pour dire qu'il était insuffisant qu'il
fallait un deuxième plan de relance que
Bruno Le Maire le ministre de l'Économie
refuse quel regard vous porté sur cet
arbitrage est-ce qu'il faut aller encore
plus loin dans la relance où est-ce
qu'on se contente de ce qui est des gens
moi je me suis prononcé sur ce sujet
dans une note du Commissariat au Plan
que je vais essayer de reprendre
l'argument
la relance ça s'adresse à ce qui existe
aux activités qui existent
moi j'ai proposé qu'on réfléchisse à une
reconquête
parce qu'il y a un grand nombre de
secteurs d'activités du pays
dont nous avons été exclus alors que
nous avions toutes les compétences et
toutes les capacités pour y figurer
et ceci est un problème national
en France l'industrie dans le produit
intérieur brut c'est 12%. et peut-être
un tout petit peu moins en Allemagne
l'industrie c'est 25%
mais en Italie c'est 19% en Espagne
c'est 16%. si nous ne voyons pas que
nous sommes en train d'être largués dans
des secteurs d'activité où nous devrions
exister alors c'est que nous ne faisons
pas face à nos responsabilités
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous
voyez que la relance ça ne suffit pas
j'espère qu'il y aura une relance pour
l'aéronautique c'est d'ailleurs en cours
il me semble que quelque chose est en
train d'aller dans le bon sens en
matière d'aéronautique pour des raisons
intéressantes et qu'on connaît
maintenant mieux et donc cette cette
reconquête est nécessaire je vais
prendre un exemple caricatural nous
sommes les premiers producteurs
européens de pommes de terre
mais nous importons nos chips et nos
flocons de purée
tout secteur quand vous êtes un pays
capable de fabriquer des satellites des
fusées des avions des des hélicoptères
les meilleures méthodes d'hélicoptères
moteurs d'hélicoptère du monde je dis ça
à destination de mes compatriotes
pyrénéens et béarnées les meilleures
méthodes moteurs d'hélicoptère du monde
quand vous êtes pourquoi est-ce que vous
êtes exclu de cette reconquête le
gouvernement ne l'a pas engagé
il devra le faire cette reconquête c'est
pour moi l'étape essentielle des années
qui viennent et c'est les 100 milliards
dont vous parlez dans ce cadre de ce
plan Marshall c'est le plan Marshall que
j'évoque qui est un plan de financement
de financement comment l'a fait après la
guerre de financement des
investissements je je
j'assen ce que je dis le problème en
France c'est que on confond
perpétuellement les domaines de
l'investissement et du fonctionnement
donc vous dites ce serait des aides pour
construire de nouvelles usines j'ai pas
dit des aides
j'ai dit
des aides à l'investissement
l'investissement des subventions ça une
caractéristique c'est pas de l'argent
perdue
c'est de l'argent que vous allez
retrouver plus tard et donc en France on
confond perpétuellement investissement
et fonctionnement il y a une bonne dette
et il y a une dette
je veux pas dire mauvaise mais qui ne
sera tramait pas quoi Bruno Le Maire ne
veut pas de ce que vous proposez mais
d'abord je ne sais pas s'il ne le veut
pas et puis on a bien le droit d'avoir
un débat et de défendre chacun des
positions la dette pour l'investissement
c'est le meilleur moyen de redresser le
pays parce que allant une un pas plus
loin si on ne le fait pas notre contra
social est insoutenable vous entendez ce
que je vous dis
le contrat social français qui est le
plus généreux du monde il est
insoutenable si nous nous rendons pas
compte qu'il est entièrement fondé sur
la contribution des gens qui travaillent
des gens qui ont des revenus c'est eux
qui financent le contrat social est-ce
que c'est est-ce que François Bayrou
c'est ce que vous mettez aussi derrière
ce que vous avez dit après les
régionales le fameux coup de ce monde
vous avez dit que ce qu'il y avait eu
dans l'abstention très forte d'un coup
de semence donna l'exécutif est-ce que
ce que vous nous dites là en fait partie
c'est à dire que les Français protestent
contre le fait que bien l'état n'est pas
assez présent pour se projeter dans
l'avenir est-ce que c'est ça le coup de
ce mot sous c'est quoi on a la très bien
compris le coup de ce mot c'est un terme
de marine vous savez c'est un coup de
canon qui est lancé en direction d'un
bateau pour l'avertir que la prochaine
fois
enfin qu'il n'y aura pas de seconde fois
la prochaine fois on le met là en
l'occurrence il se passe c'est
l'expression que j'ai utilisée je peux
en utiliser d'autres
comme quoi on nous a adressé les
Français nous ont adressé un message
recommandé
et ils attendent l'accusé de réception
alors message recommandé à qui
deux destinataires le premier
destinataire c'est la l'organisation de
la démocratie française ce que les
Français ont dit c'est votre démocratie
ne nous intéresse plus
vous nous invitez à voter on sait pas
pourquoi on vote et même dans ce studio
si je faisais une interrogation sérieuse
sur les régions les départements les les
compétences des uns et des autres les
compétences croisées des uns et des
autres et la loi électorale des uns et
des autres on vote pour deux assemblées
qui au fond se ressemblent avec deux
lois électorales fondamentalement
différentes une liste d'un côté un
ticket de l'autre tout ça il faut
mesurer que c'est incompréhensible on le
fait selon des modes de votation comme
on dit totalement archaïque mais c'est à
dire
laissez-moi ajouter deux phrases qu'il
faille aller le dimanche
que que vous ne puissiez pas voter par
correspondance aux États-Unis écoutez
bien ce chiffre
sur 200 millions de votants pour
l'élection présidentielle ils ont eu eux
une participation de plus de 75% mais le
ministre de l'Intérieur vous a dit votre
parcours
on a le droit d'avoir des débats c'est
absurde la position non pas du ministre
de l'intérieur mais de l'administration
enfin c'est ça
aux États-Unis 100 millions de votes par
correspondance et malgré les millions
investis par l'équipe Trump et n'ont pas
trouvé une fraude les Allemands ne
votent pas correspondant sur gela Merkel
l'éclate de rire elle a éclaté de rire
dans une rencontre sur le fait que les
Français n'avaient même pas le vote par
correspondance la Suisse elle vote par
correspondance c'est pas des démocraties
de deuxième zone pourquoi pas chez nous
alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui bloque
parce que chez nous le l'État est
profondément marqué par un immobilisme
une paresse de certains de certains
responsables
techno structure qui s'est changé en
verrouillage
et qui ministre après ministre leur
explique non monsieur le ministre n'est
pas possible c'est la phrase que j'ai
entendu le plus souvent quand j'ai été
au gouvernement ça n'est pas possible
c'est la même chose dans une
administration qui vous dit ça quand
vous êtes ministre ouais
l'administration et puis naturellement
les ministres sont solidaires de leur
administration parce que c'est comme ça
que ça se passe et qu'il faut une dose
d'énergie absolument irrésistible pour
faire bouger tout ça mais c'est notre
responsabilité
très longuement sur cette organisation
de la démocratie peut-être aussi parce
que vous estimez que la proportionnelle
devrait être élargi on y revient après
une courte pause à tout de suite
[Musique]
suite du Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI
invité aujourd'hui le haut-commissaire
au plan et maire de Pau François Bayrou
le débat est dirigé par Benjamin sport
touche
du Figaro et Adrien de TF1 LCI nous
parlions de comment refonder cette
démocratie et bien pour faire en sorte
qu'il est moins d'abstention on poursuit
sur ce thème Guillaume Rocket est-ce que
l'une des solutions ne serait pas que
les Français connaissent mieux leurs
élus et peut-être pour ça à revenir sur
le cumul des mandats
le nom cumule des mandats pardon c'est
ce que propose Richard Ferrand ce matin
une décision qui a été prise j'ai
moi-même j'ai moi-même soutenu je
reconnais que le résultat n'est pas
celui qu'on attendait
parce que en France la démocratie est
soumise à
une nécessité d'incarnation on a besoin
de connaître les gens et c'est vrai que
du temps il y avait un député maire on
le connaissait mieux j'ai moi-même pas
été député maire mais depuis avec
d'autres fonctions locales président du
conseil général à l'époque
on connaissait mieux
bon en même temps c'est une évolution
profonde de la société ça s'est pas fait
par hasard c'est fait parce qu'il y
avait une demande sociale très fort les
Français et donc la main voilà réclamer
il faut qu'on il faut qu'on reprenne
qu'on reprenne ça en tout cas il y a une
chose qui est absolument certain c'est
que le
l'imbrication l'imbrication
l'intrication de nos collectivités
locales des différents étages de
responsabilité locale il y en a au moins
trois et dans beaucoup de régions 4
rangs incompréhensible la démocratie
locale et une partie des messages
recommandés avec accusé de réception que
je décrivais vient de de cette
constatation on y comprend rien
et à la vérité on ne peut rien y
comprendre parce que c'est
invraisemblablement compliqué
en tout cas le l'idée que on puisse
accumuler ainsi les intercommunalités
les départements les régions les
collectivités très concrètement est-ce
que c'est les intercos ou les
départements essayons de ne pas
simplifier
de ne pas être simpliste excusez-moi
mais pour donc
les intercommunalités c'est absolument
nécessaire c'est devenu et ensuite
l'étage intermédiaire qui devrait être
un étage de fédération des différents
territoires
départements et régions ça va pas ça
dépend il y a des régions qui vont très
bien la Normandie parce que c'était
historiquement inscrit mais la
nouvelle-aquitaine qui est plus grand
qu'un grand plus grand de
géographiquement un grand État européen
qui met dans la même région je parle de
ma région qui met dans le même région
Pau et Biarritz et puis
et puis Poitiers et puis l'image et puis
Bressuire et puis bon c'est impossible
il faut 7 heures ou 6h pour aller d'un
bout de la région à l'autre c'est
inimaginablement
irrespects de ce que les histoires et la
géographie ont été alors
et puis les départements à l'intérieur
n'ont pas exactement trouver leur place
il se trouve que Nicolas Sarkozy et moi
pour une fois sur la même ligne nous
avions soutenu l'idée du conseiller
territorial je trouvais moi qu'on aurait
pu l'appeler conseiller général c'était
son nom autrefois et ça allait très bien
qui était à la fois un élu des
départements et de la région autre sujet
sur lequel vous êtes beaucoup battus la
proportionnelle Adrien Gindre on parlait
tout à l'heure référendum François
Bayrou est-ce que là par exemple c'est
un sujet sur lequel on pourrait imaginer
une consultation des Français à
l'automne pour enfin l'introduire pour
les législatives de l'année prochaine
pour moi c'est indispensable
et c'est le seul moyen que
cette loi électorale soit adoptée
le chef de fil des députés modem dit on
fait ce il suggère d'organiser ce
référendum à l'automne est-ce que vous
soutenez cette proposition je croyais
même avoir proposé cela de manière un
peu explicite alors il s'est inspiré
mais c'est le préalablement normal nous
appartenons à la même équipe donc ça
peut être l'automne on pourrait imaginer
au pire de le faire le jour des
législatives de manière que ce soit
installé dans la loi après tout ça je
suis prêt à le discuter je sais une
chose certaine c'est que les Français
ont le sentiment d'une immense injustice
devant laquelle tout le monde est
différents vous avez
60% des Français
qui sont par présentés dans leur
assemblée et l'assemblée c'est fait pour
représenter le peuple aux régionales et
ça pas conduit les Françaises on parle
d'autres choses là on parle de Lead de
du fait que les Français voient dans
leurs institutions une justice à
laquelle ils peuvent adhérer on a un
président de la République qui a et
c'est normal le l'essentiel du pouvoir
exécutif entre les mains il a et c'est
normal c'est le Président c'est
général de Gaulle qu'il a voulu il a le
la charge de former le gouvernement
c'est lui qui forme le gouvernement
c'est pas l'assemblée c'est pas les
coalitions comme autrefois sous la
Quatrième République on confond
généralement les deux général de Gaulle
a dit c'est le président de la
République qui formera le gouvernement
et il a ajouté dans son le
célébrissime discours
il a ajouté ouvrez les guillemets ils
formera le gouvernement en tenant compte
des nuances de l'Assemblée nationale
donc il faut qu'elle soit il y a
représentant que ça il faut qu'elle soit
plus réaliste et représente tous les
courants
finir la phrase je compte sur votre
réponse le la démocratie ça consiste à
donner à chacun son juste droit
vous êtes un électeur un électeur vaut
en dignité en légitimité un autre
électeur et donc lorsqu'un courant
d'opinion réunit mettons plus de 5%,
c'est toutes les démocraties qui nous
entourent au font ça ça veut dire
beaucoup plus d'un million d'électeurs
il a le droit d'être représenté et un
électeur vaut un autre électeur
l'égalité l'égalité de dignité de
légitimité
la preuve il y en a il y a pas de
proportionnelle ou alors il va y avoir
un référendum pour l'instant ça n'est
pas le cas mais il
faut pas prendre l'air moqueurs en face
de tout ça ce sont des débats absolument
essentiels pour le pays mais est-ce
qu'il est encore temps de changer les
règles oui ici 2022 d'ici les
législatifs
de fixer un calendrier si le président
de la République est comme jeu j'espère
qu'il le sera persuadé de cette
nécessité
on va on va se trouver devant des
élections législatives a supposer même
qui se représente et qui soit réélu qui
vont être qui vont pas prendre l'aspect
d'une vague comme on a pas de majorité
et donc chacun a le devoir de réfléchir
à cette règle de justice et de
représentativité quand vous dites il
faut écouter les électeurs
le la majorité a eu un très mauvais
score au dernier régional des ministres
se sont présentés ils ont été battus
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron n'aurait pas
dû en tenir compte et par exemple
remanier le gouvernement en se séparant
du ministre comme Eric Dupond-Moretti
alors c'est le deuxième message je vais
pas en tirer les mêmes conclusions que
les vôtres mais j'ai dit il y a deux
messages recommandés avec accusé de
réception c'est le deuxième message le
message c'est à la majorité à l'exécutif
et que disent ce message je crois qu'il
dit
on ne comprend pas bien ce que vous
faites on comprend pas comme vous êtes
organisé et en tout cas pour nous
on attend du changement on attend que
vous entendiez ce qu'on vous dit et moi
je suis partisan que on entend ce que
les Français ont dit alors la majorité
d'y réfléchir je pense en tout cas qu'il
faut que soit refixé le cap que soit
refixé les fondamentaux qui avaient fait
la vie qui ont fait la victoire de 2017
et dont il faut retrouver aujourd'hui la
ligne directe aujourd'hui le cap n'est
plus clair
je dis pas ça comme ça je pense que les
Français
ont cette opinion mais il doit quoi
convoquer le Congrès le prix dans la
République pour s'exprimer dans les
parlementaires c'est une option c'est
une option il y a d'autres options quels
sont-elles ces autres écoutez-les
laissez le président de la République
prendre ses décisions je veux je suis
pas là pour pour
court-circuiter ces décisions je pense
qu'il est vous les connaissez qu'il est
très nécessaire que le Président de la
République
face entendre aux Français le caractère
original et la force du projet qui est
le sien mais je pense que je pense que
ce projet du président de la République
est liée à deux questions essentielles
première de ces questions
quelle reconstruction du pays
si je prends on a pris l'industrie c'est
une chose on a des problèmes dans
la santé l'organisation de la santé la
pharmacie
l'absence de on a des problèmes de
souveraineté il y a vous le voyez bien
aujourd'hui des ruptures en termes de
matière première
il y a des secteurs qui sont très très
importants
si vous regardez on a un problème majeur
d'éducation nationale
un pays comme pour moi c'est un
crève-cœur j'ai toujours aimé cette pas
seulement aimer était passionné par
cette mission que la France
grand pays scientifique qui saigne
de ces prix Nobel soit aujourd'hui le
dernier pays du monde en termes de
compétences mathématiques à l'école
c'est pas possible et même en termes de
langue de maîtrise de la langue alors le
ministre de l'Éducation s'y est attaqué
naturellement
on est sur la fin du quinquennat vous
voyez tout à l'heure votre question
c'était vous dites qu'on peut plus rien
faire et maintenant vous dites on peut
pas changer en 10 mois on peut
s'adresser on peut s'adresser au pays
pour dire ce que vont être les
orientations fondamentales de l'avenir
pour la suite première question il y a
une deuxième question puis je
m'arrêterai là
c'est au fond quel est le rôle de la
France en Europe et dans le monde
qu'est-ce que c'est de notre projet
national mais il fera alors
l'identité nationale dans cette affaire
là ce que nous portons tous et chacun
qu'est-ce qu'on a à dire à l'Europe et à
dire au monde ces deux questions là
comment reconstruit et quel est le
message de la France sont depuis
terre à terre prosaïque mosaïque comment
est-ce qu'on le fait avec quel
organisation est-ce que par exemple une
maison commune président Edouard
Philippe pour restructurer la majorité
la remobiliser ça aurait vous faveur
cette cette manière de voir les choses
des pas la mienne il y a une question
préalable
c'est
est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui organisé
même un parfaitement comme il faudrait
ou bien est-ce que notre absence
d'organisation
est pénalisante et moi je réponds
toutes ces formations j'en ai fondé j'en
préside une
ne sont plus
en
capacité de mobiliser le pays il faut
bouger alors comment les organisations
que nous avons sont
sympathique intéressante enracinée pour
certaines ont une histoire mais elle ne
correspondent plus au défi du temps
il faut faire démocratique dont nous
parlions donc il faut reprendre
comme un architecte créer un seul grand
parcours de la majorité en tout cas il
faut une démarche unitaire
il faut un grand mouvement politique qui
est les traits dont on a besoin
démocrate pour les uns républicains pour
les autres et populaire il faut inventer
notre républicains
je vous assure Benjamin sportouche on
peut rire de la démocratie on peut rire
des parties tout le monde non mais vous
pensez en imprimez déjà pensé de cette
architecture et que oui je m'efforce de
ne m'exprimer que quand j'ai pensé un
tout petit peu donc est-ce que vous
pourriez présider ce parti est-ce que
vous pourriez le lancer et vous voulez
bien écartons les questions de personnes
y compris la mienne
je me suis beaucoup battu j'ai rompu
beaucoup de lance
au service de ce courant politique là de
ce grand courant central
qui a pour moi vocation à gouverner la
France durablement pas seulement pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle mais
pour organiser rencontrer les forces je
j'en tire cette conclusion des élections
séparées en est trop faible alors il
faut que personne n'y perde de son
identité de son histoire
de son patrimoine de valeur mais il faut
une organisation différente et que ce
soit une organisation ouverte dans
laquelle les tous ces Français qui ne
qui ne se reconnaissent plus puissent
trouver un engagement différent
pas forcément engagement d'adhérents
mais quelque chose à quoi il puisse
participer avant qu'on enlève nos
questions Express une toute petite
question encore d'actualité il y a une
perquisition mystère de la justice cette
semaine en présence du garde des sceaux
et Dupond-Moretti est-ce que vous avez
été surpris choqué est-ce que c'est
normal que les juges bien ailles au
ministère de la Justice comme dans toute
autre institution en France on peut être
surpris et choqué et en même temps
penser que les juges ont ce droit
reconnus par la constitution de
déclencher des actions y compris des
actions
du garde des sceaux les moyens
employants ont été excessifs disponible
j'ai entendu dire qu'on avait découpé au
chalumeau des coffres forts vides je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai c'est pas des
renseignements de première main même si
j'ai été au ministère de la justice
pendant une courte période
[Musique]
je vais dire quelque chose de
d'un peu
si il y a des gens qui imaginent que la
justice doit être un contre-pouvoir
et moi je pense que la justice doit être
impartiale qui considèrent ça que la
justice était vous voyez la différence
entre le contre-pouvoir
qui est une manière de
juges de prendre les les pouvoirs de la
démocratie et d'essayer de les
déstabiliser ou de les affaiblir et puis
il y a le l'autorité impartiale que la
justice doit représenter et je suis
nettement du côté de l'autorité
impartiale je j'ai trouvé que le que le
mur des cons était une obscénité et là
il y avait un peu de partialité
il y a pas eu de sanctions je pense que
quand
un certain nombre de
de personnes disent il faut aller vers
davantage de responsabilité des
magistrats
qui n'est jamais mise en cause je pense
qu'ils ont raison je pense qu'il y a un
malaise entre la justice et la société
que les citoyens et les justiciables ne
se sentent pas
sous assez souvent garantis dans leurs
droits et je pense que c'est une
reconstruction absolument nécessaire et
profonde et le garde des soporestés à sa
fonction de garde des sceaux après
certaines décisions du président de la
République et du garde des sceaux mais
pour l'instant je constate qu'il y a eu
simplement et si les mis en examen doit
partir vous poserez la question à lui il
dit que non au ministre de la Justice et
au président de la République vous
n'avez pas l'air convaincu François Baro
question express et le Grand Jury
question Express
ou contre l'interdiction du voile pour
les assesseurs dans les bureaux de vote
les bureaux de vote c'est
l'espace public et on a le droit dans
l'espace public de porter un foulard
pour ou contre le contrôle continu pour
toutes les épreuves du bac comme
envisager par Jean-Michel Blanquer
ce qui pose question dans le contrôle
continu c'est l'harmonisation des notes
et mettre sur sur la sur la tête ou sur
les épaules des enseignants une démarche
à nouveau
bureaucratique et compliqué pour
harmoniser toutes les notes de France
c'est extrêmement compliqué plutôt con
j'ai lu dans le Figaro une tribune très
intéressante plutôt contre ce sujet
récemment donc plutôt contre si je
résume votre pensée pour ou contre la
pantéonisation de Joséphine Baker
je suis le seul Français qui n'aime pas
le Panthéon
donc on ne pensait je trouve que c'est
un je m'y suis opposé enfin je me suis
opposé j'ai dit que j'étais pas
enthousiaste pour aimer ses airs pour du
mal pour des gens qui qui étaient dans
leur terre et qu'on proposait d'aller
enfermer dans ce monument
symbolique et majestueux mais froid
en tout cas moi je n'aimerais pas qu'on
mette au Panthéon quelqu'un que j'aime
et donc
il y a des gens qui sont fascinés par le
Panthéon c'est pas mon cas des gens qui
sont fascinés par les décorations il y a
des gens qui sont fascinés par les
décorations c'est pas mon cas il y a des
gens qui sont fascinés par les grandes
institutions horrifiques toutes les
académies ça n'est pas mon cas je bon
mais peut-être parce que je suis un
pyrénéen un peu éloigné de
comme disait monsieur qui s'appelait
Blaise Pascal politique franchement
Adrien Gindre on s'interroge beaucoup en
ce moment sur les ambitions
présidentielles éventuelles d'Eric
Zemmour est-ce que vous y voyez plutôt
une menace pour la majorité Emmanuel
Macron ou une opportunité de diviser la
droite d'affaiblir en particulier Marine
Le Pen
je suis pour que chacun vive ses
aventures
qui soient libres de sa vie qui l'assume
le destin qu'il a ou qu'il croit avoir
il a quelque chose à dire
40 ans et donc je vais pas me mêler de
ce genre de débat
c'est à lui comme citoyen de prendre ses
responsabilités vous avez des contacts
avec lui des discussions politiques ça
m'arrive assez souvent on n'est pas
souvent d'accord mais ça m'arrive assez
souvent est-ce que Marine Le Pen a été
affaiblie selon vous
ça hypothèque ces chances de victoire
pour 2022 la majorité a été affaiblie
le rassemblement national a été affaibli
la démocratie a été affaiblie il y a
beaucoup de d'affaiblissement et assez
peu de renforcement mais la gauche et la
droite renforcée
il le croit mais ils vont découvrir que
c'est pas si simple de dégager un leader
je parle en connaissance de cause
et ils vont découvrir que
ça n'est pas parce que vous avez une
étiquette que les gens font confiance à
la femme ou à l'homme qui se présente
devant vous c'est comme ça autrefois on
voté en fonction des étiquettes on vient
de découvrir que ce n'était pas le cas
question net et le Grand Jury
questionnaire bonjour à tous bonjour
François Bayrou dans l'actualité des
réseaux sociaux cette semaine Emmanuel
Macron a relancé le débat sur les crop
top vous savez ces vêtements qui
arrivent au dessus de la taille le
président préfère qu'à l'école ses
élèves ses filles notamment porte une
tenue décente je le cite vous vous avez
des petits enfants est-ce que ça vous
choque par exemple des enfants et des
femmes qui vont à l'école c'est ce que
ça vous choque s'ils mettent un groupe
pour y aller
je suis assez peu choquable donc pour
vous c'est une tenue décente
vous voyez bien il y a une forme de
sexisme quand j'ai
grandi au temps des mini-jupes
et j'en garde un souvenir absolument
chaleureux et ému et c'était vraiment à
l'époque des mini mini-jupes est-ce que
c'était descend bon c'était descend ça
dépend de ceux qui les portent et de
leurs attitudes est-ce que le fait
qu'Emmanuel Macron intervienne par
exemple sur la tenue que doivent porter
les jeunes filles une chose que je sais
avec certitude c'est que je respecte la
liberté y compris des gens que j'aime
bien et surtout des gens que j'aime bien
j'ai trouvé par exemple ça a été
beaucoup critiqué que sont que sont
émission je sais pas comment on dit avec
les youtubeurs
étaient
oui avec Carlito et McFly j'ai trouvé
que c'était très sympathique une autre
question j'ai trouvé qui n'avait jamais
abandonné
la dignité
présidentielle et quand même temps
c'était complètement détendu et
complètement naturel pour autant
aux élections mais vous aurez observé
qu'il y a 13 millions de jeunes je crois
qu'ils ont regardé cette production
il s'oppose aussi à l'allongement de 12
à 14 semaines du délai pour avoir
recours à une IVG le chef des députés de
la République en marche Christophe
Castaner a clairement dit qu'il avait un
désaccord avec le président est-ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à l'allongement
de ce délai
je pense que c'est une question sur
laquelle le comité d'éthique doit se
prononcer très bien donc le comité délic
avant que mais vous vous n'avez pas
d'avis particuliers vous êtes plus que
sur le 25 à 14 semaines à plus à 12
semaines
vous voyez bien les problèmes de la
sensibilité que ça pose pour moi
c'est pas indifférent
qui se développe
dans le 5 on m'ont dit de sa mère c'est
pas indifférent
la nuit il y a des lois et le comité
d'éthique doit pouvoir dire ce qu'il en
très rapidement une dernière question
entre officiellement au conseil
d'administration d'un grand groupe
pétrolier russe est-ce que vous vous
pouvez envisager de le faire est-ce que
ça vous choque et vous estimez qu'un
conflit d'intérêt ce que je peux
envisager de faire ça jamais
pas une seconde ni de près ni de loin
quand vous êtes mais vous avez été un
responsable public de premier plan
affiché de cette manière que vous êtes
sous la coupe d'un puissant État
étranger il y a quelque chose qui moi
c'est Burt et m'a toujours merci alors
on dira que dit en direct il y a des
dirigeants allemands qui l'ont fait
monsieur Schroeder en particulier moi ça
meurt quand merci quand vous allez
incarné les pays a de plus précieux à
mon sens alors c'est merci François le
dernier grand jury de la saison merci à
nos partenaires le figawel C merci à
aussi à tous les techniciens
réalisateurs qui permettent la bonne
tenue de ces émissions tout au long de
l'année un grand merci tout particulier
à Catherine Mangin et Philippe et pour
leur accompagnement mais aussi Chantal
Busson Catherine Chevillon merci à vous
tous pour votre fidélité je vous donne
rendez-vous le 29 août pour une nouvelle
saison qui s'annonce bien sur
passionnante avec l'élection
présidentielle en ligne de mire d'ici la
belle était à tous prenez soin de vous
[Musique]